(bubbles burst)
(gasps)
- I've done a lot of
dumb things for videos
but this one might just be the dumbest.
Hi, I'm Dakota and for the next week,
this bathtub is gonna be my home.
Why did I sign up for this?
(New Orleans jazz music)
You might be asking yourself, "Why?"
Well, it's pretty simple.
I work at Buzzfeed and
I'm running out of ideas.
I am gonna stay in this bathtub
for a whole week with a few exceptions.
I can leave to use the toilet,
because I am not waffle stomping
and when my roommate
needs to take a shower.
I'm also not gonna have water
in the tub the whole time,
because, as I learned that would kill me.
For everything else, though,
I am sticking right here.
What am I getting myself into?
Goodbye outside world.
Bye!
(water sloshes)
Oh, that's really hot.
Shouldn't have started with a full tub.
(exhales slowly)
Oh, that's hot. That's really hot.
(exhales)
So I didn't go into this
completely unprepared.
I did bring a few things into this room
to make myself as comfortable as possible
because I don't wanna
just survive in here,
I wanna thrive.
Everything that I use in
this video is gonna be linked
in the description down below
in case you want to do
something as dumb as I am
or just to try any of those things out.
To start, I have a cushion behind me.
This tray here is
basically gonna be my desk
where I can use my keyboard and mouse.
I also have this little
waterproof notepad next to me
because if I am in this
bathtub for a week,
I am bound to have some
incredible shower thoughts.
I don't wanna forget them.
The coolest thing of all, check this out.
(machine whirs)
(bubbles pop)
I got a jacuzzi!
I forget how to turn it off.
There we go.
And then, of course I have a
rubber duck to keep me company.
Outside of the tub is where
things get interesting, though.
I have a little rack over here
to hold all of my provisions
and I have this really cute
little Frigidaire refrigerator
that I am keeping some
of the colder foods in.
And then the entertainment center.
LG was nice enough to send me out one
of their SHort Throw CineBeam projectors,
which is really great because it works
in a small, confined space.
That's gonna be basically
my monitor as well
as how I watch movies
and play video games.
And yes, I know it's overkill,
but I figured if I can, why not?
I'm the only person I know
with a home theater in my bathroom.
Here goes a week.
What do I do?
Next thing I think--
(door knocks)
Yeah?
- [Will] Can I take a piss?
- Yeah.
(shower curtain whooshes)
Well, we're gonna get closer
than we ever thought we would.
(loud thud)
(laughs)
(toilet flushes)
- [Will] Good doing business with you.
- And you. (laughs)
I'd say this has been a
pretty successful day one.
I'm just kinda getting used to it
and hopefully I can get some sleep.
I'll see you tomorrow.
(upbeat music)
I did not sleep well.
All of my joints hurt.
I am six foot two, and this tub
is less than five feet long.
(neck cracks)
Ooh, that gives you an
idea of what it feels like.
(silly music)
(grunts)
Will is pretty busy in meetings today,
so I can't rely on him to bring me food,
but I set up something really cool
and I am excited to show it to you.
Just watch this.
All right and order placed.
I ordered from Shake Shack.
It's only three blocks away.
(silly music)
Okay, the guy just buzzed.
I am going to let him in.
(little machine whirs)
I've got this.
Let's see if this works.
I think it's coming!
Let's see if I can reach this.
(bag clatters)
(laughs)
Lunch!
(straw squeaks)
Delicious.
(New Orleans jazz music)
I've got a few meetings today
and I'm wondering if I should
take them with the water.
(curtain whooshes)
Hey!
- Well, well, well.
- See, I've got the
jacuzzi, it's bubbling.
I'm gonna turn the jacuzzi
off 'cause it's quite loud.
Oh, that just turned it louder.
Oh no, how do I, okay, wait,
no, that turned it back on.
Oh no! Off.
Why does it keep turning back on?
Stop?
I think it turned off.
- The last thing I need to happen is
for this to short circuit
while I'm on video with you.
- Important update.
I posted on Instagram asking
what I should name my duck.
And I've decided to name him Arnold.
Hey Arnold.
What's the point of being in the tub
unless you're gonna hang
out and relax in it?
So I have lit some candles for myself.
I'm just gonna relax and see
if I can get a better
night's sleep tonight.
Really hoping I can.
(peaceful music)
I'm standing up 'cause
I just took a shower
and I'm still waiting for the tub to dry.
But last night was really rough.
I felt like every part of my
body was in the wrong position.
Also, one thing I hadn't considered is
that I shouldn't take a bath
right before I wanna go to bed
because then I have to
wait for the tub to dry
before I can put my pillow
and blankets in here.
(strings pizzicato)
I can't afford to keep ordering food,
so today I'm gonna bring
a toaster in the tub.
(electricity short circuits)
I'm just kidding.
But I am gonna make some avocado toast.
Avocado, bread.
What more do you need?
I forgot to bring plates in here.
(fridge hums)
This thing got very hot,
very quickly. (laughs)
Let's toast.
Yeah.
Look at that, that's beautiful.
Look at that, it's beautiful.
Breakfast.
I feel like later I'm gonna
be bathing in bits of egg.
This is the reason the housing market
is in shambles and I have
to live in a bathtub.
It's the damn millennials
and their avocado toasts.
(upbeat music)
I realize I've been so rude.
I've been asking Will for all this help.
He's been getting me
food and I haven't even
invited him in here to watch
a movie or anything. (laughs)
Hey, Will!
- Yeah?
- Do you wanna watch a movie
and drink a beer in here?
- Yeah.
(both laugh)
- Cheers.
(movie plays)
Oh yeah, baby.
- Day three complete.
I am not looking forward
to trying to sleep tonight.
I am very tired, though, so
hopefully that will help.
3:30 in the morning, I've barely slept,
and I did exactly what I was afraid of
and started dribbling
water all over the pillow.
I just need clean up the
water, go back to bed.
I can sleep a little bit.
(sighs)
I woke up today and I hurt everywhere.
My back is sore, my legs
are completely cramped up.
I don't know if I can demonstrate this,
but my legs have to be
completely bent like this
in order to fit in this tub.
And over the course of the night,
I feel like it's
constricting the blood flow
and it's just like making me cramp up.
I just wanna stretch them,
but I have nowhere to do that.
And so I wake up constantly.
I need to move around, like actually walk.
So while my roommate takes
a shower this morning,
I'm gonna go for a quick walk.
I'm not giving up, I just
need to move for 20 minutes.
It's so nice out.
Why do I have to go back into this tub?
(sighs)
(somber music)
I don't wanna get back in there.
(blows raspberry)
Halfway done.
(upbeat music)
(spoon clinks)
So if this is gonna be my home,
I figure I might as well start decorating.
So I've been adding some art to the walls.
This one I call Lost Arnold and this one
is what I think paradise looks like.
There's no bathtubs there.
And I'm currently drawing
the view out my window
if I could see out my window.
I will start the bidding at $1 million.
(cash register rings)
I'm doing great.
I have to finish editing a video today,
but after that, I think
I'm going to take the rest
of the day off and just relax.
I'm gonna go live on Twitch,
and stream myself playing
video games from my bathtub.
(water rushes)
It's raining. I'm
already wet in real life.
I don't need to get wet in Minecraft
Ow, I don't have much health left, dammit!
(groans) Oh it's wet!
I got some of it up my nose.
That stream tonight was really fun.
I actually enjoyed myself
and I kind of forgot
what I was doing for a little bit.
And it kind of just made me realize that,
yeah, I can do this.
It's gonna be hard, it has
been hard, but it's possible
and I'm almost there.
(uplifting music)
Good morning from day five.
I just took a shower if you couldn't tell.
Last night, I decided to sleep sitting up,
which I usually try to
avoid because I can never
stay asleep long that way.
I can't sleep on buses
or planes or anything.
However, maybe it's because
the last few nights of sleep
have been truly awful, or
maybe I'm just built different,
but I managed to just sleep
mostly through the night.
Also it's Friday, which means
I've just got a few days left
of this and then I'm free.
I was sitting here trying to figure out
what to do with my day and it struck me
that Arnold needed a friend.
And so I've been converting
this shampoo bottle
into a friend for Arnold.
Her name is Dove.
("Wedding March" plays)
They're getting married
and all the soaps are invited.
Just look at them so happy together.
(music slows)
(bottles thud)
Whoops.
(imitates kissing)
(broadcast signal)
I wonder how long I can
hold my breath under water.
I'm gonna try it.
(inhales deeply)
(bubbles burst)
(gasps)
I'm out of practice, but not terrible.
I invented a game.
Since I have a tennis ball and
I have a roll of tape here,
and all you have to do is
bounce the tennis ball off this
and into the roll.
I'm really bad at it.
(ball thuds)
(gasps)
(fanfare plays)
Let's call my mom.
She picked up!
- What's up?
- I just wanted to call and say hi.
- You're in your bathroom.
- I am in my bathroom.
My home theater set up over there.
- That's great, right over the toilet.
- Yeah, it's perfect.
- Aren't you out of there yet?
Your mother's worried
about your wellbeing.
- I'm gonna be fine, don't worry.
- Are you comfortable.
- Um, sure.
- Drive Will crazy that you're...
- I'm sure I owe him something, big time.
He has gone to the neighbors'
to use the bathroom.
- Why are you doing this?
- For content, Tucker, for content.
(somber music)
It's my last day in this tub.
I'm actually about to get
out in just a few minutes.
I didn't expect it to
be this hard. (laughs)
I mean, I should have, in retrospect.
I should have thought, "Wow,
that's not a good idea.
You shouldn't get in that tub."
But I did and here I am.
The past seven days I have left this tub
for probably an hour, total, just in times
where I needed to change my clothes
or grab something that I really needed.
It took its toll.
I physically don't feel great,
my body feels kinda achy.
And honestly I think the hardest
part has been the boredom.
I'm lucky I had a bunch of fun stuff
to do in here because if I hadn't,
I would have completely not
been able to get through this.
There's no profound
thing coming out of this.
This was just a nightmare.
This was just not a pleasant time.
I do not recommend it to anybody.
Don't do it.
I might have to move.
I don't know if I wanna see
this bathroom anymore. (laughs)
All right.
Oh, okay.
Ooh, my butt's wet.
(inspiring music)
I'm free!